d vous ce week end sur public sénat
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat dans un instant vous allez pouvoir
suivre la discussion des conclusions de
la commission mixte paritaire sur le
projet de loi hôpital patients santé et
territoires en présence de roselyne
bachelot la ministre de la santé qui a
été reconduite dans ses fonctions hier
ce projet de loi a été adopté à
l'assemblée nationale par 179 voix pour
contre 117
mais jusqu'au bout ce texte aura fait
l'objet d'intenses débats hier le
gouvernement a déposé un amendement de
dernière minute pour tenter de revenir
sur la question de la gouvernance de
l'hôpital
cet amendement a finalement été rejetée
cet après midi ce texte devrait être
adopté définitivement après un ultime
vote des sénateurs bonne après midi à
tous sur public sénat l'ordre du jour
appelle maintenant la discussion des
conclusions du rapport de la commission
mixte paritaire chargée d'élaborer un
texte sur les dispositions restant en
discussion sur le projet de loi portant
réforme de l'hôpital et relatif aux
patients à la santé et aux territoires
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à notre collègue alain milon
rapporteur pour le sénat de la
commission mixte paritaire
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre tout
d'abord madame me permettez moi de
saluer votre nomination au poste que
vous teniez déjà de vous dire combien je
suis heureux à titre personnel de
pouvoir continuer de travailler avec
vous mes chers collègues à l'examen des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire qui s'est tenue mardi dernier
16 juin au sénat
nous arrivons aujourd'hui à la dernière
étape de la discussion de ce projet de
loi hpst
le président nicolas bour a pu dire que
ce projet doit avait été celui de tous
les records
la liste de ces records n'était pas
close car il est sans doute inédit car
rapport de cmp dépasse les 450 pages
mais au delà des records au delà des
statistiques
l'important méchas collègues et que
cette longue histoire finisse bien
la commission des affaires sociales se
félicite donc que la commission mixte
paritaire
et puis parvenir à un texte commun sur
les 127 articles encore en discussion
parmi lesquels figuraient les plus
importantes dispositions du projet de
loi
je crois pouvoir dire aussi que ces
travaux ont été de grande qualité et que
chez se sont déroulées dans un climat
très constructif ce qui est pour nous
comme pour nos collègues députés un
motif de satisfaction supplémentaire
nous sommes aussi heureux pourquoi ne
pas le dire que le sénat est apportée à
ce texte
des contributions significatives qui sur
de très nombreux points ont été
entérinés par la cnp au titre premier
relatif aux établissements de santé et
aux missions de service public
la cmp a apporté des aménagements
rédactionnelle de précision ou de
coordination qui n'ont pas remis en
cause l'économie du texte adopté par le
sénat
je voudrais souligner madame la ministre
le souci commun des deux assemblées de
définir à cet article la notion nouvelle
des speak établissement de santé privé
d'intérêt collectif dont la cmp a prévu
en retenant le texte du sénat qu'ils
pourraient conclure des accords avec un
établissement public ou une communauté
hospitalière de territoire les associant
à la réalisation de missions de service
public
sur le même sujet il me paraît également
très positif que nous ayons pu nous
accorder à l'article 28 du titre iv
j'anticipe un peu sur une rédaction
permettant comme l'avait souhaité le
sénat de conférer le statut des siic à
des établissements ou services sociaux
ou médico-sociaux l'article 3 bis qui
peut permettre d'imposer une clause de
non concurrence aux praticiens
hospitaliers à titre permanent avait été
adopté par le sénat contre l'avis du
gouvernement du président de la
commission et du rapporteur de la
commission des affaires sociales il a
fait l'objet d'un long débat en
commission mixte paritaire
celle ci a finalement décidé de le
maintenir mais en adoptant un amendement
présenté par notre collègue député jean
leonetti elle en a restreint le champ
d'application aux praticiens ayant
exercé plus de cinq ans dans le même
établissement
en ce qui concerne la gouvernance de
l'hôpital public
la cmp a largement confirmé les
dispositions adoptées par le sénat pour
fonder son efficacité comme le proposait
le rapport larcher sur un meilleur
équilibre entre les instances
gouvernantes et entre pouvoirs
administratifs et médicaux à l'article 5
elle a toutefois revenons sur ce point
au texte de l'assemblée nationale prévu
que le président du conseil de
surveillance serait désigné
soit parmi les membres du collège des
élus soit parmi ceux du collège des
personnalités qualifiées
cette solution madame à nice tu avais
nous savons la préférence du
gouvernement
d'excellents arguments ont été invoqués
à l'appui des chats respectifs des deux
assemblées et je ne discuterai pas celui
de la commission mixte paritaire
je rappellerai cependant comme le fait
au cours du débat ancien p plusieurs de
nos collègues que les élus sont souvent
les moteurs de la modernisation des
hôpitaux locaux est toujours les acteurs
essentiels de la lutte contre les
inégalités territoriales en matière
d'accès aux soins
la cmp n'a en revanche pas modifié la
définition renforcée par le sénat des
compétences du conseil de surveillance à
l'article 6 relatif aux directeurs et au
directoire
elle a partagé le souci du sénat de
favoriser la coopération et le dialogue
entre les médecins et l'administration
vous avez cependant modifier son texte
sur un point en présentant à l'assemblée
nationale un amendement un amendement à
nos conclusions la commission mixte
paritaire suivant le sénat et
conformément d'ailleurs à l'esprit du
texte du projet de loi avait en effet
exprimé clairement que certaines
décisions du directeur devrait être
précédé la consultation du directoire
vous avez préféré que le texte prévoit
seulement que ces décisions seront
prises après concertation avec le
directoire
nous le regrettons un peu d'abord parce
que cette expression est imprécise et
parce qu'il serait mal moi un peu et
parce qu'il serait malaisé de contrôler
le respect cette formalité mais surtout
s'être aidé cette rédaction d'un
ministre restreint à nos yeux la portée
des dispositions que nous avions adopté
à votre initiative pour donner dans le
directoire des chu comme le souhaitait
la commission marescaux leur juste place
aux autorités responsables de la
formation
on et de la recherche le président de la
cme élabore rats avec le directeur le
projet médical et coordonnera comme nous
l'avions souhaité la politique médicale
de l'établissement
la définition des compétences du
directoire reste celle qui résultait du
texte du sénat cette instance approuve
le projet médical prépare le projet des
épices mans et conseils
le directeur sur la gestion et la
conduite de l'établissement la cmp a
maintenu l'ensemble des mesures que le
sénat avait adopté pour introduire plus
de collégialité dans la gouvernance des
établissements de santé en impliquant
davantage le président dassier me dans
le processus de contractualisation
interne
celle-ci se prononcera sur
l'organisation d'établissement en pole
d'activité définis par le directeur il
participera à la nomination des chefs de
pôles en présentant une liste de noms au
directeur il émettra un avis sur les
contrats de pôles afin de vérifier leur
cohérence avec le projet médical
la cmp a également retenu que l'épaule
pour en comporter des structures
internes unités fonctionnelles service
et que leur gestion devra s'effectuer
dans le respect des missions propres à
ces structures
elle n'est pas revenue sur le fond de
l'article 12 relatif aux communautés
hospitalières de territoire dont le
sénat avait souhaité que la rédaction
correspondent à la philosophie du
rapport larcher
elle a toutefois prévu la possibilité
d'imposer des transferts de personnels
entre établissements partie à une
convention de cht
le sénat avait estimé que ce transfert
pourrait être négociée est consentie
nous souhaitons que dans le fait cela
soit le plus souvent le cas notre
commission des affaires sociales espère
mes chers collègues que la cht ainsi
conçu deviendra un outil nouveau
permettant d réorganisation territoriale
de l'offre de soins fondés sur un projet
médical élaboré et réalisé
par tous les acteurs locaux et
permettant aussi l'instauration d'un
réel dialogue entre les élus les
professionnels de santé et
l'administration
les dispositions de l'article 13 voilà
tifo groupement de coopération sanitaire
et à la coordination par la rs de
l'évolution du système hospitalier ont
également été adoptées dans le texte du
sénat sous réserve d'ajustements
rédactionnelle est d'une précision utile
adopté à l'initiative de jean marie
rolland qui ouvre aux syndicats un
terreau spitalier la faculté de se
transformer en groupement d'intérêt
public une sous le titre 2 du projet de
loi relatif à l'accès de tous les ce de
tous à des soins de qualité
la commission mixte paritaire a pour
l'essentiel adopté le texte du sénat
elle a confirmé les progrès accomplis au
sénat en matière de délégation de tâches
et de santé des femmes qui passent à un
renforcement du statut des sages-femmes
et l'intégration de leur formation à
l'université à l'initiative du groupe
crc spg la cmp a également décidé de
permettre à titre expérimental la primo
délivrance de contraceptifs oraux par
les formations elle a entériné le
dispositif de validation des acquis de
l'expérience pour l'obtention d'un
diplôme de formation médicale
spécialisée adopté par le sénat est
attendu par de nombreux praticiens sur
les dispositions largement consensuel
concernant la rénovation des andes
médicaux et paramédicaux la commission
mixte paritaire
suivant le sénat a supprimé le seuil
démographique imposé pour la création de
conseils départementaux d ordre des
infirmiers et masseurs kinésithérapeutes
initiative d'yves bur de jean pierre
door de jean luc préel elle a adopté à
l'article 17 ter à l'amendement
sous-amendé par françois autain incitant
à la négociation d'ici au 15 octobre
prochain d'une convention permettant
d'encadrer la presse
du secteur optionnel cher à notre
collègue alain vasselle à défaut d'un
accord dans ce délai sans doute un peu
bref pour régler une question aussi
complexe
un arrêté des ministres chargés de la
santé la sécurité sociale pourra
modifier les dispositions de la
convention nationale des messages
généralistes et spécialistes
cette disposition mais chaque collègue
peut constituer un signal a dit
s'initier à destination des
professionnels sur les dépassements
d'honoraires
cependant il me semble que la question
de la revalorisation des actes d'abord
être abordée pour reconnaître la
reconnaissance réel des actes médicaux
sur la question sensible des
discriminations de l'axé hausse dans
l'accès aux soins
la cnp à préciser les délais dans
lesquels les refus de soins pourront
être sanctionnées par les caisses
primaires d'assurance maladie et
revenant sur ce dernier point un texte à
l'assemblée nationale les mesures de
publicité de ces sanctions
il convient de lutter contre les
comportements contraires à la dir
l'automne à des ontologies
professionnels le sénat et l'assemblée
nationale ont clairement devrait dans le
même sens pour clarifier la procédure et
rendre le système de sanctions plus
efficaces
enfin la cmp à partager le souci de
transparence qui avait conduit le sénat
à rendre obligatoire l'information des
patients sur le coût d'achat des
prothèses et leurs lieux de fabrication
elle a aussi retenu mes dispositions que
nous avions prévu pour assurer la
continuité des soins aux malades sortant
de l'hôpital
j'en arrive au titre iii consacré à la
santé
nous avons cherché à retirer son contenu
sur les dispositions les plus novatrices
du texte et celles touchant à
l'organisation de notre système de santé
les autres sujets pourront être renvoyée
au projet de loi sur la santé publique
et sur la santé mentale que vous
que vous nous avez annoncé madame la
ministre nous avons cependant maintenu
certaines dispositions
s'inscrivant dans le cadre du plan
cancer ou de nature sociale comme la
possibilité d'acheter des fruits et
légumes avec des tickets restaurants sur
le volet alcool nous sommes revenues
après un débat approfondi à l' équilibre
trouvé à l'assemblée nationale sur
l'éducation thérapeutique du patient
la cmp a approuvé le dispositif de
financement adoptée par le sénat
nous porterons une particulière
attention aux futurs rapports sur les
possibilités de passage à un financement
public des associations sur la nutrition
et la lutte contre l'obésité
la commission mixte paritaire a suivi le
sénat et a maintenu la suppression des
articles introduits par l'assemblée
nationale
hormis l'article 25 des sièges qui
insère dans le code de santé publique
un livre consacré aux troubles du
comportement alimentaire sans aborder le
vrai sujet de la nutrition le titre
quatre relais tout à fait le titre iv
relatif à l'organisation territoriale du
système de santé avait été
substantiellement amendé par notre à
sonde en ce qui concerne les agences
régionales de santé et la détermination
des responsabilités nationales et
régionales en matière de gestion du
risque
il nous paraît important que la
commission mixte paritaire est adoptée
dans le texte du sénat les dispositions
de l'article 26 b prévoyant la
conclusion entre l'état et la gamme de
contrats pluriannuels définissant les
objectifs de politique nationale de
gestion du risque comme celles de
l'article 26 dans l'ems latitude aux ars
pour arrêter les actions régionales en
matière de gestion du risque
le texte de la cmp ne remet pas non plus
en cause le parti pris par le sénat de
clarifier
et d'alléger la rédaction de certaines
dispositions de l'article 26 et de
souligner que la politique de santé est
une politique nationale dont les ars
permettront l'application déconcentrer l
adaptation aux spécificités régionales
et territoriales
après un large débat
la cmp a cependant repris à l'initiative
de nos collègues députés
une disposition du texte de l'assemblée
nationale permettant de confier à titre
expérimental monsieur le président la
présidence du conseil de surveillance de
certaines ars a une personnalité
qualifiée désignée par le ministre la
santé nous avons aussi répondant au
souhait commun du rapporteur pour
l'assemblée nationale et dessinateur
socialiste réintroduit la mention des
observatoires régionaux de la santé
enfin la cmp a maintenu le texte du
sénat en ce qui concerne la consultation
sur le projet régional de santé des
représentants des collectivités
territoriales et de la conférence
régionale de la santé et de l'autonomie
ainsi que la liberté pour les
collectivités territoriales d'accorder
des subventions aux services de santé
sur l'article 27 27 pardon relatifs à la
représentation des professionnels de
santé libéraux alors que le sénat avait
prévu de regrouper les électeurs des
unions régionales de médecins en collège
sans en préciser le nombre
la commission mixte paritaire a préféré
revenir à la répartition en trois
collèges prévu par l'assemblée nationale
un dernier mot pour finir sur les
apports de notre assemblée au volet
médico-social qui ont été maintenus par
la cmp
j'ai déjà évoqué les explique médico
sociaux je mentionnerai aussi
l'intégration dans les contrats annuels
d'objectifs et de moyens conclut par les
établissements médico-sociaux
d'objectifs de qualité
de prise en charge la garantie dans le
cahier des charges de l'appel à projets
de la qualité de l'accueil et de
l'accompagnement des personnes
dépendantes
la possibilité dans le cadre de l'indh
aux actes de la vie courante d'apporter
une aide à la prise de médicaments
la cmp a en revanche estimé que
l'instauration en cas de grève d'un
service minimum dans les établissements
médico sociaux ne pouvait être imposée
par la loi sans concertation préalable
nous nous sommes ralliés en point de vue
de nos collègues députés avons adopté un
amendement prévoyant madame la ministre
que le gouvernement remettra au
parlement avant le 30 juin 2010 un
rapport relatif à la mise en oeuvre ont
regardé contrainte constitutionnelle
d'un service minimum dans le secteur
médico social
mes chers collègues au moment de
conclure ce long travail
je voudrais vous remercier tous oui au
moins tous ceux qui ont travaillé
remercier tous et vous êtes nombreux à
avoir participé aux débats
particulièrement évidemment les membres
de notre commission et tout
particulièrement si vous le perdez
éviter mais permettez notre président
nicolas ben je rends également hommage
au président de séance qui pendant de
longues heures ont dirigé ce débat je
voudrais aussi mesdames
madame la ministre vous dire notre
gratitude pour votre écoute et
l'excellent climat dans lequel nous
avons travaillé avec vous je vous
demande donc dans mes chers collègues au
nom de la commission des affaires
sociales d'adopter le projet de loi dans
le texte issu des travaux de la
commission mixte paritaire
merci monsieur le rapporteur
permettez moi au nom du sénat de vous
féliciter vous remercier pour
l'importance du travail que vous avez
accompli comme rapporteur
tout au long de ce texte
les associés le président de la
commission et l'ensemble des membres de
la commission mais je les leur j'irai à
l'ensemble de ceux qui sont les
collaborateurs de la commission pendant
toute cette période
la parole est maintenant madame roselyne
bachelot narquin ministre de la santé et
des sports monsieur le président cher
gérard larcher mais c'est le président
de la commission des affaires sociales
sheikh nicolas abou monsieur le
rapporteur
cher alain milon mesdames et messieurs
les sénatrices et sénateurs
je ne peux pas vous cacher en ce jour ma
joie de vous retrouver et c'est avec une
très grande fierté que je vous retrouve
donc aujourd'hui pour achever l'examen
d'un texte fondamental pour notre
système de santé
après des semaines je devrais dire des
mois d'ailleurs d'un débat riche souvent
intenses
passionné à l'assemblée nationale
d'abord puis avec vous ensuite et après
le remarquable travail de la commission
mixte paritaire
nous pouvons nous féliciter d'être
parvenus à un texte d'équilibré un texte
responsable la fierté que je ressens est
celle d'une ministre dont l'action se
veut entièrement guidé par une seule et
même exigence améliorer l'accès de tous
nos concitoyens à des soins de qualité
elle est celle également d'une ministre
qui ayant fréquenté de longues années
les bancs du parlement mesure exactement
l'investissement et les exigences qui
sont requis pour faire vivre
un tel temps fort de la vie démocratique
de notre pays
aussi je voudrais profiter de cette
nouvelle occasion qui m'est donnée pour
remercier toutes celles et tous ceux qui
ont contribué par la finesse de leurs
analyses et de leurs propositions à
enrichir ce projet de loi je veux
remercier en particulier gérard larcher
pour son rapport exceptionnel sur les
missions de l'hôpital
je mesure tout ce que cette loi lui doit
vous dois monsieur le président trouver
ici l'expression de ma gratitude
le rapport de jean marc julia a lui
aussi constituer une contribution
majeure
je tiens à remercier le président de la
commission des affaires sociales nicolas
à bout pour sa hauteur de vue sa grande
expertise sa sensibilité aux enjeux sa
grande intelligence recueille toute mon
admiration
ce sont les gilles la commission des
affaires sociales a parfaitement su se
saisir de l'enjeu majeur que représente
ce projet de loi pour l'avenir de notre
système de santé
et vous l'avez fait monsieur le
président dans des conditions
particulièrement difficiles avec un
changement de règlement qui nous ont
obligés parfois à quelques réglages mais
vous avez su le faire avec beaucoup
d'humanité de gentillesse et de
compréhension donc à nouveau ma très
grande gratitude je veux rendre hommage
à votre rapporteur alain milon pour sa
précision son écoute permanente et je
dois dire que les applaudissements qu'il
vient de recueillir
je n'avais pas le droit d'y ajouter les
miens étiquette parlementaire oblige
mais j'aurais volontiers accompagner vos
applaudissements par les miens je
n'oublie pas non plus la contribution de
tous les sénateurs qui sur tous les
bancs et l'airé de la compétence notre
discussion
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs de l'opposition vous ne m'avez
pas ménagé je ne demandais pas non plus
et je sens d'ailleurs que ça va
continuer dans quelques instants
mais j'ai toujours eu à coeur d'écouter
vos contributions avec respect dans
retenir un certain nombre et de le faire
dans un bon esprit démocratique et
républicain merci grâce à vous de
l'ambiance qui a régné pendant cette
discussion mais vous comprendrez sans
peine
mesdames et messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs de l'opposition que mes
pensées reconnaissante vont évidemment
aux sénateurs et sénatrices qui m'ont
toujours soutenu
soutenu dans ce débat je pense à à marie
thérèse hermange à gérard dériot à
catherine procaccia jean pierre fourcade
andré lardeux la vaste scène gilbert
barbier anne marie payet lui ghedini que
tout ce que je n'ai pas cité ne m'en
veuillez pas c'est la loi des
énumérations que forcément isabelle
debré qui est là
tous se trouvaient ici donc à nouveau et
toute ma profonde reconnaissance aux
poils blancs etc
oui joue alain gournac vous avez bon jeu
voilà la façon de se faire des amis et
des ennemis définitif en tout cas soyez
toutes et tous remercier pour votre
apport est vraiment que ce que je ne
suis pas ne m'en tienne pas rigueur
finalement sans l'apport de chacun ce
débat parlementaire aurait eu peu de
sens
je voudrais adresser un remerciement
tout particulier aux membres du sénat
ayant participé à la commission mixte
paritaire où ils ont su trouver un
compromis qui respecte la volonté de
chaque assemblée
le travail mené par la cmp est en effet
un travail difficile nécessitant
beaucoup de finesse d'esprit de synthèse
il en est d'autant plus j'ose le mot
extraordinaire
aujourd'hui je veux en toute sincérité
exprimé la gratitude du gouvernement
sans reprendre dans le détail toutes les
mesures d'un projet de loi d'envergure
j'aimerais vous rappeler tout ce que
ensemble nous avons accompli et que nous
allons donc apporter à nos concitoyens
nos hôpitaux ont été modernisées la
gouvernance de l'hôpital a été rénové
clarifier pour donner à tous les acteurs
d'exercer pleinement leur rôle et leur
mission les prises de décisions seront
facilitées tous les patients en
bénéficieront pour mieux répondre aux
besoins de santé de nos concitoyens qui
veulent pouvoir bénéficier de parcours
de soie fluide et de qualité nous avons
voulu également faciliter les
coopérations hospitalières mieux
articuler le système hospitalier avec la
médecine de ville et le secteur médico
social
le projet de loi permettra également de
mieux répartir l'offre de soins sur le
territoire pour lutter contre ce que
beaucoup d'entre vous ont appelé les
déserts médicaux
grâce à des mesures cohérentes nous
répondrons à l'exigence d'un accès au
soin pour tous dans le respect de la
liberté d'installation formation offre
de soins rien n'a été oublié
toujours nous avons fait le pari de
l'organisation et de la modernisation
parce que cette loi est une loi de
prévention il était bien naturel que le
préventif aux côtés du curatif trouve
une place accrue
le titre relatifs à la santé publique
comporte des mesures fortes sur les
déterminants de santé en particulier
nous pensons bien entendu ôter au tabac
et à l'alcool
l'inscription de l'éducation
thérapeutique dans le code de la santé
publique et pas seulement une évolution
c'est une révolution culturelle qui
instaure une nouvelle relation entre le
soignant et le soigné le malade sera
désormais véritablement l'acteur de sa
propre santé
enfin la création des agences régionales
de santé parachève le décloisonnement de
notre système de santé sans doute à des
plus cloisonnés et a déplu regalia du
monde
leur mission sera en particulier
d'organiser l'offre de santé sur tout le
territoire au plus près de nos
concitoyens tout le champ de la santé et
de l'autonomie se trouve désormais
investi ce trop bref résumé dit il ah
c'est la valeur et l'importance d'un
texte innovant et pragmatique qui se
veut aussi ambitieux et responsable
j'aimerais vous dire toute la confiance
qui est la mienne dans cette réforme
élaboré avec tous et pour tous pourtant
monsieur le rapporteur là soulignait il
subsiste une légère ambiguïté sur le
mode de fonctionnement du directoire
ambiguïté tout relaté une ambiguïté
relatives à la manière dont il est
consulté par le directeur dans
l'exercice de ses fonctions et de ses
compétences en ont entendons nous bien
lever cette ambiguïté ne remet
absolument pas en cause l'équilibré
trouvé entre les directeurs et les
médecins cet équilibre a été
parfaitement traitée par la commission
mixte paritaire la volonté du
législateur telle qu'elle s'est exprimée
sur tous les bancs et que le directoire
soit une instance collégiale
lieu d'échangés entre ses membres c'est
aussi l'avis du gouvernement pour autant
il ne faut pas que cette instance ploie
sous un fonctionnement trop formaliste
au les experts juridiques consulter ces
derniers jours par le gouvernement nous
un texte nous indique que le texte issu
de la cmp peut transformer le directoire
en une instance consultative formelle
qui fonctionnent avec des règles de
quorum des comptes rendus des scrutins
où chacun compte ses voix alors que ce
doit être une instance de discussion
collégiale opérationnel et finalement
s'inspirer de ce qui marche bien c'est à
dire du fonctionnement des actuels
conseil exécutif personne n'a imaginé
dans le cheminement qui nous a amené à
ce texte qu'il en soit autrement
les règles de fonctionnement du
directoire doit faciliter des échanges
nécessaires pour prendre en compte les
différents points de vue l'expression de
ses points de vue indispensable au vu de
l'originalité de la structure
hospitalière
mais le formalisme doit être
proportionnée j'ajoute que la rédaction
initiale du gouvernement indiquant après
consultation n'évitait pas non plus cet
écueil
je le concède bien volontiers elles
garantissent l aspect collégiale mme
hedegaard insiste ne garantissait pas
non plus la recherche d'un consensus
positif
c'est pourquoi nous avons besoin d'une
forme d'une formulation plus
satisfaisant
l'amendement que je vous propose est
donc un amendement technique permettant
de lever une ambiguïté il substitue un
terme à un autre tout en conservant ce
que vous avez souhaité c'est à dire le
principe d'un travail en plein
collégialité au sein du directoire et il
est donc cohérent avec les souhaits
exprimés par les deux assemblées et au
total monsieur le président je
considérerais donc avoir défendu quand
je présenterai l'amendement l'avoir
descendu
au final ce texte consacre une réforme
indispensable
adapté aux besoins et aux attentes des
français destiné à accompagner notre
notre société dans les défis qui se
posent pour tout ce qui la portera nos
concitoyens je crois que nous pouvons
être collectivement fier de ce projet de
loi
merci à tous et à toutes merci madame la
ministre
dans la suite de notre discussion
générale la parole est maintenant aux
présidents guy fischer je suis le
président
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues au terme de nos
quatre semaines de débats en séance
publique sur ce projet de loi je ne vous
surprendrai pas en réaffirmant devant
vous aujourd'hui que le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et des
sénateurs du parti de gauche votera
contre ce texte
mr permettez-moi tout de même avant de
revenir au fond de notre opposition de
dire quelques mots sur les conditions
dans lesquelles ce projet de loi a été
travaillé en commission et la manière
dont il a été débattu en séance publique
ce projet de loi était véritablement le
premier à être discuté sous les auspices
de la nouvelle procédure destinée selon
les dires de ses défenseurs à renforcer
le rôle des parlementaires
toutefois en lieu et place d'un tel
renforcement
nous avons insisté au contraire à une
forme d'un menuisier mandé droits des
parlementaires notamment en raison des
délais de dépôt d'amendements trop court
par ailleurs je voudrais regretté qu'en
réponse aux amendements que nous avons
défendu en séance publique le rapporteur
et eu trop souvent comme seule
explication quant à sa position recours
à une formule renvoyant les
parlementaires et ceux qui suivent les
débats au décision prise préalablement
en commission des affaires sociales
cette réponse pour nous n'est pas
satisfaisante dans la mesure où
contrairement aux séances publiques les
débats en commission ne font pas l'objet
d'une publicité complète et oui alors
nous saurions que trop invité les futurs
rapporteur à ne pas recourir à une telle
formule
au risque de voir les parlementaires
notamment de l'opposition délaissé le
travail en commission pour se consacrer
à la science publique ce qui me semble
être le contraire des objectifs
poursuivis par la réforme
constitutionnelle est réglementaire par
ailleurs si le gouvernement
dispose de la possibilité de déposer des
amendements à tout moment au cours de
nos débats nous préférerions qu'ils en
usent avec parcimonie les délais entre
la date limite de dépôt des amendements
l examen par le sénat de ceux ci en
sciences public lui laisse tout loisir
de déposer les amendements qu'ils
estiment nécessaire mais permettez moi
d'en venir au fond au début de nos
travaux mon ami françois autain ah non
c'est qu'avec cette réforme tout
convergeait vers la privatisation du
service public hospitalier
après la réunion de la commission mixte
paritaire
je ne puis que confirmer ces propos en
effet dès le premier titre de ce projet
de loi dès son article 1er le ton est
donné
vous procédez à l'emblématique
suppression de la notion de service
public hospitalier est divisé la mission
qui était la sienne en 13 missions
distinctes séparées permettant aux
établissements de santé privés
commerciaux d'opérer parmi ses missions
les choix les plus rentables
aujourd'hui déjà plus de 60% des actes
de chirurgie sont réalisés par le privé
commercial à n'en pas douter cette
proportion aura pour les opérations les
plus rentables tendance à s'accroître
dans l'avenir
quant aux missions les moins rentables
en apparence du moins comme l'accueil
d'urgence des patients elles serviront
toujours pour le privé commercial à n'en
pas douter
comme nous l'avons déjà dénoncé dans nos
débats d'aspirateur à patientèle pour
notre part nous considérons que cette
division en 13 missions est profondément
contraire à l'esprit de notre
constitution et notamment de son
préambule nous considérons qu'elle
desservira les intérêts des patients
notamment des plus démunis tout en
renforçant le poids des établissements
de santé privés commerciaux
de la même manière
nous entendons rappeler notre opposition
à la possibilité offertes dans ce projet
de loi aux établissements de santé
privés commerciaux d'ouvrir des centres
de santé cette mesure constitue là
encore un outil nouveau ans directeur du
secteur commercial lui permettant
d'attirer dans leur établissement des
patients qui naturellement se serait
dirigé vers les établissements de santé
publique
et ce d'autant plus que vous avez refusé
notre amendement visant à préciser que
les patients accueillis dans des centres
de santé gérés par des établissements de
santé privés lucratifs bénéficient dès
lors qu'il poursuivre les soins de la
clinique gestionnaire et bien d'une
tarification sans dépassements de la
même manière vous avez refusé notre
amendement visant à sanctionner
spécifiquement les personnes physiques
et les établissements de santé privés
commerciaux qui bien que chargé de
mission de service public de santé ne
respecterait pas les tarifs définis dans
le code de la sécurité sociale pour les
établissements de santé publique
tout cela nous donne l'impression et les
nombreux partenaires que nous avons
rencontrés durant nos débats et après
nos deux groupes d'ailleurs a été à
l'initiative
après le vote de la loi en première
lecture notre groupe a été à
l'initiative d'une rencontre de
conclusion de nos travaux qui a réuni au
sénat près de 100 participants et bien
ceci nous l'ont confirmé que cette loi
si elle était adoptée est sans doute le
sera t-elle dans quelques minutes
eh bien elle permettra au secteur privé
lucratif de venir concurrencer le
secteur public
cette concurrence est d'autant plus
important qu'elle portera sur les
missions les plus rentables
or en raison de l'application de la
tarification à l'activité
la t2a contre laquelle seuls nos deux
groupes a voté cette opération de
transfert date et donc de ressources
aura pour effet d'appauvrir encore plus
les établissements publics de santé vous
permettant demain
justifier de la non rentabilité de ces
établissements pour imposer contre les
intérêts des patients et de leurs
familles la fusion voire la fermeture
d'un certain nombre d'entre eux madame
la ministre vous organisez la
concurrence des services publics dans le
seul but de les fragiliser encore un peu
plus personne à parler jusqu'à présent
de la fermeture voire de la fusion de
200 à 300 établissements hospitaliers de
proximité
mais quels sont les enjeux de la même
manière nous sommes opposés à la
disposition permettant à des non
fonctionnaires de diriger des
établissements publics de santé
alors nous avons bien compris madame la
ministre en agissant de la sorte vous
entendez permettre l'émergence dans les
hôpitaux d'une culture différente à
celle aujourd'hui en place cette culture
de santé publique de services publics au
bénéfice d'une culture nouvelle celle
d'entreprises dont la nécessité
d'imposer un manager un directeur
manager à un hôpital entreprise durant
nos débats nous vous avons interrogé sur
les compétences non c'est pas reparti je
confirme mes propos non non ça continue
et jusqu à la fin de cette réunion est
bien de cet abat ils arrivent ils
arrivent
voilà bah il faut dans la politique
alors durant nos débats nous vous avons
interrogé sur les compétences nouvelles
que vous espérez réunir en autorisant à
des non fonctionnaires de diriger les
hôpitaux
vous ne nous avait jamais répondu et
nous le regrettons
si nous ignorons tout ces nouvelles
compétences nous savons lesquels seront
malheureusement perdu au premier rang
desquels les compétences en santé
publique sans doute les directeurs nos
fonctionnaires seront plus sensibles que
les directeurs fonctionnaires qui se
font une certaine idée dormition plus
sensibles aux exigences de rentabilité
et aux nouvelles contraintes financières
que vous entendez imposées aux
établissements publics de santé
cette décision s'inscrit par ailleurs
dans un plan de plus grande ampleur de
démantèlement de la fonction publique
hospitalière prélude à une opération
encore plus vaste et dangereuse de
privatisation des missions de service
public à l'exception de quelques rares
missions régaliennes que soit la
sécurité l'armée la justice
c'est un autre débat mais par ailleurs
je ne puis que dénoncer ici l'amendement
déposé et adopté en cmp assouplissant
encore plus mesure puisque demain les
directeurs des établissements de santé
publics non fonctionnaires n'auront plus
contrairement à ce que nous avions
défendu ici à recevoir une formation
complémentaire de l'école des hautes
études de santé publique
il suffira qu ils reçoivent une
formation de la part d'un organisme
compétent
cette formation cette formulation
ambiguë inquiète et participe à sa
manière un peu plus encore od m'est
réellement du service public de santé
par ailleurs nous continuerons à nous
opposer à la création des groupements de
coopération sanitaire des établissements
de santé
nous considérons que ces établissements
parce qu'ils permettent la participation
indistincte des établissements de santé
privés commerciaux comme d'intérêt
collectif et des hôpitaux dans une même
structure aura pour conséquence de créer
la confusion auprès des usagers et
permettra encore une fois une
d'illusions une dilution des missions de
service public
cette disposition madame la ministre mes
chers collègues me paraît juridiquement
incertaine elle serait par ailleurs très
difficile à mettre en oeuvre
et ce d'autant plus que les principaux
partenaires concernés la fée ap et la
fhf annonce ne pas vouloir y participer
cette privatisation du service public
hospitalier en 13 mission correspond à
l'exigence permanente de la droite la
plus libérale de france et d'europe de
réduire les dépenses publiques
un objectif qui n'acceptent
aucune contradiction y compris la plus
fondamentale la pertinence de cette
politique au regard des intérêts de la
population
eh bien nous en doutons en france cette
politique porte un nom la révision
générale des politiques publiques la
fameuse rgpp qui prévoit l'année
prochaine et bien de supprimer 36 mille
postes de fonctionnaires
les agences régionales de santé données
directeurs sont de véritables super
préfet sanitaire sont les instruments de
cette politique de rigueur
j'en veux pour preuve la possibilité
qu'il aurait aimé ça fait plaisir de
dire alors je vois pas pourquoi vous
monde empêcherait riez un merci monsieur
nécessaire j'en veux pour preuve la
possibilité qui leur est offerte par la
loi de placer seul sans concertation
avec les partenaires sociaux et les élus
locaux les établissements publics de
santé déficitaires sous administration
provisoire
c'est à dire sous tutelle il procédure
dont on comprend qu'elle n'aura que pour
seul objectif le retour à l'équilibré
pour notre part nous continuons de
penser que les déficits que subissent
les hôpitaux ne sont pas exclusivement
le fait d'une mauvaise gestion des
établissements de santé par leur
directeur nous considérons qu'elle
résulte d'un double mouvement
la convergence public privé le paiement
à l'acte qui ont pour conséquence
d'appauvrir les hôpitaux en les privant
des ressources nécessaires à l'exercice
de leurs missions
il s'agit sans doute là madame la
ministre d'une divergence de fond entre
nous mais nous considérons que certaines
missions de service public notamment
dans le domaine de la santé ne peuvent
par nature être rentable la santé ne
sera jamais contrairement aux rêves de
certains une marchandise l'hôpital
public souffre en fait de son sous
financement de la même manière nous
entendons dénoncer l'adoption par sinaï
pour
remis en cmp qui autorise des directeurs
des ars a exigé des directeurs des
établissements publics de santé qu'ils
offertes dans le cadre de leur plan de
retour à l'équilibré à des suppressions
de postes on va vers une généralisation
de plan de retour à l'équilibré avec des
suppressions de postes qui de toute
évidence seront très nombreuses
cette mesure est la preuve de ce que
nous avons des dossiers durant nous
débat ce projet de loi ouvre la voie à
un large plan social à l'hôpital pouvant
se concrétiser selon les estimations de
la fédération hospitalière de france par
la suppression de 15 20 mille emplois à
terme
bien sûr cela ne se fera pas tous les
jours mais chaque année apportera son
lot de suppressions de postes et c'est
cela que nous dénonçons ce mouvement
madame la ministre est déjà en oeuvre
je ne reprendrai pas comme j'ai pu le
faire dans nos débats la longue liste
des hôpitaux qui aujourd'hui déjà
procède à des suppressions de postes
notamment par le biais des
non-remplacements des départs à la
retraite mais il ne fait nul doute que
demain pour satisfaire à l'exigence
présidentielle du non remplacement d'un
fonctionnaire sur deux partant à la
retraite
ce mouvement aura tendance à s'accélérer
pourtant nos concitoyens qui sont les
usagers des hôpitaux dénonce précisément
le manque de moyens y compris en termes
de personnel lesquels personnel
notamment paramédicaux dénoncent quant à
eux des conditions de travail
insoutenables
dans ce contexte il n'est pas acceptable
de rajouter de la pénurie à la pénurie
enfin concernant les questions
salariales
nous entendons nous opposé à
l'amendement adopté en cmp autorisant le
transfert automatique des personnels
d'un établissement de santé publique
participantes à une communauté
hospitalière de territoire vers un autre
établissement participant à cette cht
cette automaticité en lieu et place du
volontariat que notre haute assemblée
avait instauré et pour notre groupe la
démonstration
lorsque la cht sera demain un outil
supplémentaire de réduction de dépenses
et de concentration des structures au
détriment des établissements jugés par
les pouvoirs publics comme trop petit et
pas assez rentable cela nous renvoie aux
débats que nous avons eus en séance
publique sur le caractère contraignant
de la participation à une c'est acheter
ou à un groupement de coopération
sanitaire puisque le directeur de
l'agencé régionale de santé pourra
décider demain de sanctionner
financièrement les établissements qui
refuseraient d'y participer avec ses
dispositions
tout est fait pour redessiner une
nouvelle carte sanitaire
une nouvelle carte hospitalière au
détriment des besoins des populations
mais conformes aux exigences de
rentabilité et de réduction des dépenses
publiques cher à votre gouvernement pour
permettre l'application de cette
politique de rigueur
vous aviez besoin d'un outil
administratif et politique de
circonstance la création des agences
régionales de santé
et bien c'est chose faite puisque vous
instaurez les véritables super préfet
sanitaire qui se substitueront demain
aux représentants des collectivités
locales et territoriales qui tire
pourtant toute leur légitimité du
suffrage universel
aussi je ne peut que dénoncer ici
l'adoption en cmp avec la fiv invariable
notre rapporteur d'un amendement
autorisant la présidence du conseil de
surveillance des établissements publics
de santé par des membres du 3e collège
c'est à dire des personnes qualifiées
là où précisément notre assemblée
représentant les territoires et les
collectivités locales avaient fait le
choix d'une présidence par un élu je ne
reviendrai pas ici sur notre opposition
fondamentale à la substitution des
conseils d'administration par les
conseils de surveillance dont les
compétences et les missions sont réduits
au simple contrôle je tiens à le redire
nous sommes opposés à cette conception
issus du secteur privé commercial
prive les personnels non médicaux
notamment administratif et ouvrier de la
véritable participation à la direction
des établissements de santé dans
lesquelles ils faisaient
nous considérons que précisément parce
que les hôpitaux ne sont pas des
entreprises comme les autres il est
impératif pour assurer la réussite de
leur mission particulière d'associer
toutes celles et tous ceux qui
participent quotidiennement à la
réussite des hôpitaux français dont les
réussites et les qualités sont reconnues
mondialement internationalement en lieu
et place d'une loi d'associations des
personnels et des compétences
vous avez préféré construire une loi
d'opposition d'exclusion et de
cloisonnement
alors si cette loi est une loi de
méfiance à l'égard des personnels des
établissements publics de santé qui va
très loin puisque le conseil de
surveillance n'aura même pas à se
prononcer sur le budget de leur
établissement elle est également une
noix de défiance à l'encontre des élus
locaux et des représentants des
collectivités territoriales la
présidence du conseil de surveillance
des futures agences régionales de santé
ne peut nous satisfaire
en autorisant la présence de ces
conseils par des personnalités
qualifiées
tout désigné directement ou
indirectement par le gouvernement qu'il
s'agisse des nominations formulées par
les directeurs des ars eux-mêmes nommé
par le ministre en charge de la santé ou
par celle faite par le préfet par les
préfets de région nommée par le
gouvernement
vous témoignez indirectement d'une
défiance sans précédent allait à
l'encontre des élus locaux et des
représentants des collectivités locales
et territoriales qui participe pourtant
pleinement particulièrement dans le
domaine médico-social au financement des
opérations menées dans les régions et
les départements
en réalité pour éviter toute
contestation notamment sur la faiblesse
des financements et sur les fermetures à
venir des établissements vous avez
préféré taire la contestation
le schéma que vous avez retenu est il
faut le dire contraire à l'esprit que
nous nous faisons de la démocratie
sanitaire vous préférez pour cela muselé
les oppositions organiser le contrôle de
l'état par l'état cela n'est pas madame
la ministre à la hauteur des enjeux
nous entendons également dénoncé avec
force la conception même l émission
donner aux ars
vous avez entendu et madame la ministre
a été clair sur ce sujet faire des
agences régionales de santé
l'accord clés de la dépense publique en
santé puisqu'elles seront de votre aveu
même madame la ministre
un nouvel opérateur de la gestion du
risque santé
cela témoigne de la volonté de votre
gouvernement de peser directement sur la
dépense publique sur la dépense sociale
et plus particulièrement sur la dépense
hospitalière comment considérer comme
étant la plus importante et nous avons
mille fois entendu monsieur vasselle
dire que le déficit de l'assurance
maladie était constituée au moins pour
moitié par lé les dépenses hospitalières
et donc il fallait contraindre ses
dépenses cette analyse mais connaît un
autre sens la réalité des faits qui se
traduit par une explosion continue des
dépenses de soins de ville
mais plus grave encore cela constitue
une véritable reprise en main des
dépenses de santé par l'état
rompant avec l'esprit du conseil
national de la résistance dans le seul
objectif de permettre à votre
gouvernement de peser sur les dépenses
publiques
et quand le président de la république
utilise le conseil national de la
résistance pour développer son discours
politique
nous sommes en total désaccord pourtant
nous considérons qu'il y avait d'autres
solutions et nous aurions préféré qu'en
lieu et place d'une action sur les
dépenses
votre gouvernement se consacre à assurer
des ressources nécessaires au
financement de notre protection sociale
notamment en revenant comme le suggère
chaque année la cour des comptes lors de
l'examen par le parlement des projets de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale sur les quelques 42 milliards
d'exonérations de cotisations sociales
consenties aux entreprises de notre pays
en 2009
ouais mais c'est surtout les patrons qui
encaisse monsieur vasselle par ailleurs
du corps vous savez les les salariés et
bien ne vois absolument pas leur fiche
de paye bouger au contraire ils voient
leur fiche de paye se rétracter et nous
assistons depuis quelques années à un
écrasement des salaires et des retraites
voilà la vérité par ailleurs nous
considérons que cette loi ne sera pas de
nature contrairement à l'intitulé de son
titre iii à garantir l'accès de tous à
des soins de qualité
nous avons au cours de nos débats
formulé de très nombreux amendements
destinés à résorber deux phénomènes qui
impacte indéniablement l'accès de tous
aux soins les déserts médicaux est les
dépassements d'honoraires
la majorité du sénat soutenu par le
gouvernement a malheureusement refusé
tous nos amendements destinés à résorber
les déserts médicaux
c'est à dire les zones géographiques
dans lesquelles l'accès aux soins est
devenu compliqué ou impossibles en
raison du manque d'implantation des
professionnels de santé
pourtant nous l'avons tous dénoncé aussi
la situation est des plus paradoxales
jamais le nombre de professionnels de
santé n'a été aussi important et jamais
leurs accès n'a été aussi difficile pour
notre part nous avons défendu l'image où
l'idée à l'image des politiques menées
en allemagne en autriche où au québec
d'un m1 d'un aménagement de la notion de
liberté d'installation afin que celle ci
ne soit pas en contradiction avec les
intérêts des populations
vous avez écarté toutes ces pisse
renonçant ainsi à garantir le droit
fondamental de tous nos concitoyens à
accéder aux soins
votre gouvernement aura pour l'avenir la
lourde charge d'assumer votre posture de
renoncement et devra 1
ou l'autre s'en expliquer devant nos
concitoyens qui dans les zones de
montagne n'est ce pas ni david de
campagne où les quartiers populaires non
plus ou que difficilement accès aux
soins
à ce titre je voudrais regretter
l'adoption sempe d'un amendement visant
à supprimer la disposition introduite au
sénat
proposé par mon amie annie david qui
précisait que le comité de massif été
tenu informé de la situation de la
démographie médicale dans les
territoires qui les concernent
et bien cette position cette volonté de
rompre avec l'information des comité de
massif est une preuve supplémentaire de
votre conception des contre-pouvoirs
serait d'autant plus qu'il s'agissait
d'une demande forte de l'anem dans
laquelle participent des représentants
des communes de toutes les sensibilités
politiques
de la même manière je regrette le refus
de la majorité du gouvernement de
légiférer dans le cadre de ce projet de
loi sur les dépassements d'honoraires
dont nous savons combien il constitue
une entrave particulièrement importante
dans l'accès aux soins
je ne reviendrai pas pour éviter
d'alourdir mes propos sur les résultats
du grand estime menées par les
associations des balades sur l'accès aux
soins des bénéficiaires de la cmu ou de
la m1 mais il permet tout de même
d'observer à ceux qui pouvaient encore
en douter que contrairement à nos grands
principes républicains la discrimination
dans l'accès aux soins est également
fondée sur les ressources financières de
nos concitoyens soient que certains
praticiens refusent de soigner les plus
pauvres soit que même renonce en raison
de l'absence de professionnels à tarifs
opposables à consulter un médecin
c'est surtout vrai pour les spécialistes
et ce d'autant plus qu'ils sont déjà de
plus en plus nombreux à opérer des choix
entre les soins urgents et ce qu'ils
peuvent attendre la faute aux franchises
médicales à la crise économique qui
frappe les plus pauvres d'entre nos
concitoyens de manière particulièrement
aiguë et qui se traduit par exemple par
une vague
du mouvement de démutualisation alors
j'ai bien noté madame la ministre
la timide avancée résultant de
l'adoption cmp d'un amendement sur le
secteur optionnel
il est trop timide pour avoir des effets
suffisant est réel et présente
l'inconvénient majeur de renvoyer
l'action non pas à la discussion
parlementaire mais au secret de l'action
par décret ou au plfss de 2010 j'aurai à
ce sujet une suggestion à vous faire
depuis plusieurs années il est devenu la
coutume que le plfss soit l'objet d'un
débat particulier il portait sur lors du
précédent plfss sur l'hôpital compte
tenu de l'intérêt des françaises et des
français
dessinatrice et d'essai d'un tort sur ce
sujet je vous propose de consacrer le
débat à venir sur la question des
dépassements d'honoraires est de laisser
les parlementaires qui ont fait preuve
durant nos travaux de beaucoup
d'imagination libre d'agir par voie
d'amendement vous pouvez alors compter
sur les sénateurs de notre groupe pour
défendre une nouvelle fois des
amendements qui nous sont chères à
l'image du testing de l'inversion de la
charge de la preuve de l'interdiction
d'installation des professionnels en
secteur 2 dans les zones sous denses ce
qui constitue selon nous des mesures
nécessaires et urgents par ailleurs je
tiens à rappeler en association avec mon
amie isabelle pasquet l'opposition notre
groupe à la suppression des cros mme et
à leur remplacement par une procédure
d'appel à projets alors ce mécanisme
inspiré du secteur privé commercial nous
sans être totalement opposé à l'histoire
du mouvement médico social qui fait sa
force aujourd'hui
nous l'avons dit durant nos débats nous
ne sommes pas contre une certaine forme
de décentralisation mais nous souhaitons
qu'elle soit plus solidaire nous voulons
faire vivre une véritable démocratie
sanitaire renforcée par rapport à la
situation actuelle
la suppression de la consultation des
cross sur les schémas départementaux
revient en réalité à se priver de
compétences de savoir-faire d'analystes
diverses et complémentaires
sur un schéma qui a arrêté tous les cinq
ans revêt pour les personnes en
situation de dépendance et de handicap
et pour leurs familles une grande
importance nous le regrettons d'autant
plus que la consultation de cette
structure régionale aurait permis de
confronter au niveau régional qui est
considéré donc dans le projet de loi
comme pertinents les différents schémas
départementaux dans un souci de
solidarité et d'équité territoriale
alors nous craignons également d'une
part que cette suppression ne se
traduisent en fait par la création d'une
concurrence entre les établissements et
d'autre part que ce choix ne privilégie
la plupart du temps le moins-disant
économique au détriment du mieux disant
social et on offrira ainsi un boulevard
aux établissements privés comme les
associations concernées je crains que la
réponse à un cahier des charges
prêtables i en privilégiant un processus
uniforme ou vers le bas
plutôt qu'un processus partant du
terrain de favorise des grands
opérateurs et des projets trop formaté
au détriment des projets innovants or
c'est bien d'innovation puiser dans sa
longue expérience dont le secteur
médico-social fait preuve depuis 50 ans
comment peut-on le déposséder ainsi de
sa capacité à inventer au plus près des
besoins des personnes handicapées
ce n'est pas la mise en place d'un
cahier des charges allégées par les
projets à caractère expérimental ou
innovant qui va leur rendre d'initiative
surtout quand on supprime la ministre
est qu'il n'ya qu'une mini ce pour le
secteur handicapé dans tous les cas il
s'agira avant tout de garantir une mise
en concurrence qui sera à n'en pas
douter contraire aux intérêts des
personnes concernées et croyez moi les
restes à charge seront d'autant plus
important pour les familles enfin avant
de conclure
cette longue intervention qui témoigne
de la richesse de nos travaux et de
l'ampleur des différences qui nous
oppose
je voudrais prendre quelques minutes
pour a beau aborder de dispositions qui
nous inquiète
tout d'abord avec mon amie nicole borvo
cohen seat chantant renouveler
l'opposition de notre groupe à la
suppression du statut particulier de
l'ap-hp elles témoignent encore de la
volonté de nous reprise en main de
l'organisation hospitalière dans son
ensemble et aura pour conséquence de
mettre à mal
l'unicité de l'ap-hp qui faisait
pourtant sa spécificité et a permis
jusqu'à aujourd'hui à la fois une prise
en charge des populations les plus
diverses qui composent la région
parisienne tout en permettant à
l'hôpital public au travers des hôpitaux
de la région parisienne d'être à la
pointe de la recherche médicale mondiale
ce démantèlement inquiète les personnels
de l'ap-hp y compris les directeurs de
services qui étaient réunies il y à peu
en assemblée générale à l'hôpital
saint-antoine à paris et nous ont fait
part de leurs inquiétudes et craignent
la case d'un outil formidable composé de
37 établissements actuellement au
service des populations
je ne perds pas de vue que parfois dans
des territoires désertés par la médecine
de ville qui considère certains
territoires comme pas assez rentable
l'offre publique est la seule à
accueillir les patients
aujourd'hui je voudrais dire à ses
personnels de l'ap-hp que nous sommes à
leurs côtés et qu'ils pourront compter
sur nous pour défendre partout le modèle
public seul garant du droit de tous à
accéder sans distinction de ressources
d'origine ou de pathologies à des soins
de grande qualité
enfin je voudrais dénoncer ici
l'amendement adopté en cmp tendant à
supprimer la disposition introduite
unanimement au sénat précisant dans la
loi que l'accès aux gynécologues
médicaux ne relevait pas du parcours de
soins étaient d'accès direct cet
amendement est un mauvais signal envoyé
aux femmes particulièrement aux jeunes
femmes de notre pays qui pourraient ne
plus recourir à cette spécialité
cette décision est d'autant plus
importante qu'elle s'inscrit dans une
pénurie grandi
cent deux gynécologues obstétriciens une
pénurie qui constitue un véritable haut
risque contre la santé des femmes madame
la ministre monsieur le président
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
je vous remercie de m'avoir si bien
écouté mais en l'état du projet de loi
particulièrement après son passage en
commission mixte paritaire
et bien notre groupe votera résolument
contre ce projet de loi
merci merci chez un président fischer
maintenant la parole est un monsieur
jean pierre godefroy
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues nous faisons ce
récit donc arrivés au terme de la
procédure législative l'examen de ce
projet de loi hôpital patients santé
territoires quatre semaines de débats
une centaine d'heures en séance un
rapport de cmp record environ 450 pages
en fait près de six mois de travail pour
le rapporteur la commission sous
l'autorité de son président
les administrateurs et fonctionnaires de
la commission avant d'entrer dans le
détail de la scène puisque c'est l'objet
de notre discussion aujourd'hui je veux
d'abord revenir sur la façon dont mes
collègues du groupe socialiste et moi
même avons abordé l'examen de ce texte
chaque année notre pays consacrent près
de 200 milliards d'euros aux dépenses de
santé si c'est l'un des systèmes les
plus coûteux c'est aussi et surtout l'un
des plus performants au monde
pourtant les dysfonctionnements sont de
plus en plus nombreux
engorgement des urgences allongement des
délais de rendez-vous complexification
du parcours de santé difficulté assurer
la permanence des soins
augmentation du taux de retour des
soignés crise des vocations déserts
médicaux etc
enfin notre système de santé est fragile
même si nos concitoyens reconnaissent à
juste titre la qualité des soins qui
leur sont prodigués ainsi que la valeur
des personnels soignants
c'est pourquoi une réforme d'évidence
s'imposer céder à l'un des seuls points
sur lesquels nous aurons était d'accord
mais au lieu de conforter notre modèle
de solidarité sociale de garantir
l'accès de tous dans tous les
territoires à des soins de qualité et de
promouvoir l'efficience de notre système
d'organisation des soins
ce projet de loi organisant fait le
démantèlement du service public
hospitalier et la privatisation de notre
système de santé dans votre texte madame
la ministre
d'ailleurs il n'ya plus d'hôpital public
mais les établissements santé ce qui
n'est pas neutre
on va y venir monsieur le président
justement c'est pourquoi tout au long de
ce débat nous nous sommes efforcés de
dénoncer les aspects dangereux de ce
texte mais surtout nous sommes attachés
à défendre une autre vision de la
modernisation de notre système de santé
pour nous cela passe par une politique
hospitalière volontariste et ambitieuse
une vaste réorganisation de la médecine
de ville et à pilotage régional
s'appuyant sur un renforcement de la
démocratie sanitaire et social au lieu
de cela
votre projet doit madame la ministre
affaibli l'hôpital public laisse la
médecine de ville à ces
dysfonctionnements et à ses dérives et
met en place un pilotage centralisé et
autoritaire qui ne laisse que bien peu
de place un démocratie sanitaire
pourtant essentielle ces dernières
semaines le débat s'est largement
focalisée sur la réforme hospitalière
c'est en effet avec un aspect important
du texte sur lequel nous sommes en
profond désaccord avec votre logique
c'est pourquoi nous avons insisté sur
quatre points fondamentaux
premièrement le refus du morcellement
des services des missions de service
public
le président en confiant à tous les
établissements de santé qu'ils soient
publics ou privés la possibilité
d'assurer tout ou partie des missions de
service public
le texte ouvre la porte à un service
public à la carte ou les cliniques
privées pourront choisir émissions les
plus lucratives
l essai aux hôpitaux publics le soin
d'assumer les missions les plus
délicates et les plus coûteuses comme
l'inde l'aide médicale d'urgence ou
encore la lutte contre l'exclusion
sociale
deuxièmement la nécessité de donner l
hôpital public des moyens à hauteur de
ses besoins
depuis de trop nombreuses années
l'hôpital et sous financée et reçoit des
moyens inférieurs à ses besoins minimums
de fonctionnement de nombreux projets
d'investissement sont gelés l'hôpital se
paupérise et perd les moyens pour
répondre aux défis de la médecine de
demain
en programmant comme vous le faites
année après année et vos prédécesseurs
aussi budget après budget son
étranglement
c'est bien la fin de l'hôpital public
prépare troisièmement la nécessité de
revoir les modalités d'application de la
tarification à l'activité t2a et
d'abandonner l'objectif de convergence
tarifaire entre hôpitaux publics et
cliniques privées car c'est la négation
de la spécificité des missions de
l'hôpital public qui les choisit ni ses
patients ni les pathologies qu'ils
traitent leurs peurs que vous avez
annoncé concernant la convergence est
une bonne chose
ce n'est pas suffisant quant à la
tarification à l'activité
nous nous avez envoyé au préfet cesse
nous verrons madame la ministre ce qui
on sera en tout état de cause il est
bien évident que le maintien à 100% de
la tarification à l'activité est
véritablement l'arrêt de mort des
hôpitaux publics
quatrièmement le refus de cette énième
réforme de la gouvernance
si si quatrièmement le refus de cette
énième réforme de la gouvernance qui
calque la gestion des hôpitaux sur
celles des établissements privés autour
d'un patron appelé avant tout être un
gestionnaire financier aux ordres de
l'état sans véritable association des
équipes soignantes et en négligeant le
rôle des élus locaux sur ce premier
volet du texte la cmp n'a pas permis
d'inverser la tendance
au contraire elle est même revenu sur
deux points essentiels adopté par le
sénat et l'a d'abord fait marche arrière
sur la présidence du conseil de
surveillance des établissements après
d'âpres débats avec le gouvernement le
sénat avait voté un amendement de notre
collègue jean pierre chevènement qui
permettaient de confier cette présidence
à un élu local traduisant ainsi son
attachement traditionnels ou pouvoir des
collectivités territoriales mais la cmp
a décidé de revenir au texte initial est
de permettre de confier cette présidence
à une personnalité qualifiée nommée par
le premier représentant de l'état soit
le directeur de la rs ou le préfet nous
l'avons déjà dit
selon nous l'absence de fondements
démocratiques à la nama à des
nominations dépenses et personnalités
qualifiées ne leur permet pas de se
substituer à des élus pour la présidence
du conseil de surveillance
nous ne comprenons pas cette défiance
envers les élus qu'ils ce n'est pour
renforcer la tutelle déjà très strictes
mises en place par le texte
ouvrir un processus de concurrence
électorale au sein des conseils de
surveillance nous semble périlleux pour
l'avenir madame la ministre elle ensuite
la cmp considérablement affaibli la
portée du dispositif de non-concurrence
que le sénat a introduit au profit du
secteur hospitalier
certes l'article d'après était
simplement et purement supprimée comme
vous en aviez l'intention initiale
c'est le rapporteur c'est à vous je
m'adresse part de la mme la ministre
mais l'adoption d'un amendement entre
guillemets leonetti ajoutant un délai de
cinq ans à la date d'obtention du statut
de praticien hospitalier rend de facto
cette clause de non-concurrence
quasiment inapplicable
c'est particulièrement dommage alors que
le secteur privé lui c'est parfaitement
faire jouer ce type de clause
là encore vous mettez les hôpitaux
publics en déséquilibre de concurrence
avec le secteur privé
s'agissant de la médecine de ville
comment ne pas voir et dénoncer le
contenu dr mens insuffisant des
dispositions prévues par rapport à
l'objectif fondamental qui doit être
celui de l'accès égal accès aux soins
c'est pourquoi nous avons insisté sur
une triple nécessité d'abord améliorer
la répartition des médecins sur le
territoire
le problème est urgent mais le texte
renvoie la solution à plus tard la
régionalisation du numerus clausus ne
produira aucun effet avant une dizaine
d'années si tenté que ça puisse produire
un effet quant aux contrats de santé
solidarité
il ne pourra pas s'appliquer avant 2013
nous en sommes persuadés
il est aujourd'hui nécessaire d'aller
plus loin et de frais les installations
dans les zones excédentaires
je les ai déjà dit je le redis sans
drame d'autres professions comme les
infirmières ou infirmiers ont montré
l'exemple dans une démarche
conventionnelles en subordonnant dans
les zones très denses les installations
au départ ce n'est pas dramatique
aujourd'hui les médecins ne peuvent pas
rester à l'écart d'une réflexion une
régulation est indispensable
vous aviez l'intention de bouger un
moment donné madame la ministre tout
début du texte
malheureusement vous avez dû renoncer
à cette attention qui était notre avis
tout à fait juste il faut absolument que
les médecins comprennent qu'ils ne
peuvent pas camper sur un refus total
d'aménagement du droit d'installation
ensuite luttait contre le refus de soins
aujourd'hui en france
des citoyens ne peuvent plus se soigner
en raison de leur appartenance sociale
ces discriminations vont à l'encontre
des préceptes fondateur de la république
et pourtant il ne reste rien des mesures
initialement prévu pour protéger les
usagers contre ces refus de soins
renforcement de la charge de la preuve
testing aggravation des sanctions rien
n'a trouvé grâce aux yeux de la majorité
qui a choisi de privilégier l'intérêt
des médecins plutôt que celui des
patients l'idée émise à l'instant même
par mon collègue guy fischer d'un débat
sur ce sujet lors du périph ss mais
semble vu l'urgence de la situation tout
à fait pertinent et enfin mettre un
frein aux dépassements d'honoraires qui
exclut de plus en plus de concitoyens de
l'accès aux soins sans mesure ni
contrôler ces derniers relèvent du
mercantilisme médicale
rien ne justifie qu'ils échappent à un
encadrement mais pourtant une fois de
plus le gouvernement a refusé de traiter
ce sujet la cmp a quand même permis
l'adoption d'un amendement qui invite
invite les partenaires conventionnels à
négocier d'ici le 15 octobre prochain
les modalités de mise en oeuvre d'un
secteur optionnel sens et permettent une
pratique encadrer les dépassements
d'honoraires
sinon le gouvernement sera autorisé à
procéder par arrêté eh bien ce sera une
lutte était mieux me semble-t-il que
nous en débattions et que nous votions
dans le cas de ce texte parce que le
problème se pose depuis tellement
longtemps je ne vois pas pourquoi on
renvoie à une énième concertation dont
on pourrait juge déjà le résultat mes
chers collègues
oui mais le résultat nous verrons mais
c'est prévu c'est à 7 ans minimum dans
ce qui a été mis dans lequel je pense
que c'est un placebo de ça on attend
matière médicale
même si nous dit on c'est efficace
cela fait cinq ans que le dossier est
bloqué et malgré nos demandes réitérées
le gouvernement a toujours refusé d'agir
s'agissant de l'organisation du pilotage
territorial
nous regrettons une occasion manquée la
création des agences régionales de santé
aurait pu être une véritable innovation
permettant de décloisonner notre système
de santé
en rapprochant la médecine de ville de
la médecine hospitalière pour une plus
grande efficacité
au départ c'était même une idée qui
faisait consensus mais en fait madame la
ministre vous avez conçu ces ars comme
des super structure technocratique qui
s'inscrit dans une logique d'étatisation
et consacre l'avènement de véritables
préfets sanitaires
je ne vais pas reprendre la formule
qu'il avait employée dans cet hémicycle
qui avait fait bondir un peu mon
collègue guy fischer voudrais pas le
fâcher une seconde fois
voilà laissons pas embarquer avec de
tentes supplémentaires monsieur le
président oui oui j'arrive aussi le
président alors donc je vous dis que
c'est une véritable innovation
permettant d'exposer notre système de
santé en reprochant la médecine de ville
de la médecine hospitalière pour une
plus grande efficacité
mais en fait madame la ministre vous
avez conçu comme je ne vous dira une
super structure technocratique
c'est une logique d'étatisation je viens
de le dire qui consacre l'avènement de
préfet mais ma sanitaires il faut le
répéter
en effet un pouvoir sans partage est
accordée au directeur de la rs en même
temps qu'il renforçait la chaîne de
responsabilités exécutives contrôlée par
l'état et que sont affaiblis ou isoler
les intérêts locaux les acteurs
territoriaux la régionalisation et
simplement byzance est au service d'une
brosse centralisation dont l'objectif
principal est la maîtrise des dépenses
de santé
je ne parlerai pas longtemps les volets
santé du texte tant son contenu nous
semble à la fois véritablement
insuffisant est totalement incohérent
en témoigne la controverse sur l'alcool
qui rend encore une fois animé les
débats
vous avez à l'ancien de l'amisom
prochaine loi santé publique nous
l'attendons avec impatience
bref et je vais conclure monsieur le
président on est loin de l'objectif
initial du texte qui attend en tandem
moderniser leur système de santé mais
qui finalement nous propose une vision
cloisonnée et étriquée alors que
s'imposait de la forme globale
accompagné d'investissements structurels
majeurs
progressivement les objectifs
économiques prennent le pas sur les
enjeux de santé publique et d'égalité
d'accès aux soins
r en un peu plus inéluctable l'avènement
d'une usine à deux vitesses ce choix
politique alliée à la perspective de 20
milliards d'euros de déficit de la
sécurité sociale que nous enregistrerons
à la fin de l'année et 30 milliards
annoncés par monsieur le ministre du
budget pour 2010 risque fort d'accentuer
cette rupture fondamentale à n'en pas
douter
l'examen du projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale sera 16 décisif
pour l'instant garder notre système de
protection en attendant ce futur débat
le groupe socialiste vous fera connaître
son vote par la voix de mon collègue
bernard cazeau même si certains nos
amendements ont été adoptés ils ne
peuvent changer l'orientation négative
de cette réforme
je vous remercie merci monsieur notre
foi nous allons tendre maintenant
monsieur bernard cazeau toujours pour le
groupe socialiste
sur le président m'amena ministre mes
chers collègues dans l'hôpital ne
restera pas dans les annales sinon pour
les remous qu'elle a provoqué au sein du
monde de la santé
je n'ai pas connaissance à rémy nice
d'une seule catégorie d'acteurs de la
santé qui se soit réjouit de
l'élaboration et des mesures de ce texte
ce texte qui aura battu des records
d'impopularité et qui est déjà décriée
avant d'être appliquée il faut
comprendre il faut qu'au mans n'ont ni
vous ni vous même la milice est ce que
ça comporte mais je suis bien obligé de
vous répondre mais pas en temps
puisqu'on m'interrompez il faut
comprendre le sentiment d'humiliation de
ces praticiens hospitaliers qu'on a tout
d'un coup soupçonné de contribuer à la
mauvaise gestion de l'hôpital alors
qu'ils en sont les piliers et qu'il
porte aux ou le savez bien pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux les couleurs
de la médecine dans le de la médecine
française dans le monde
faut mesurer le scepticisme des médecins
libéraux qui voit dans vos propositions
une hyper administration de leurs
activités et peu de solutions sont bien
le dire à leurs difficultés
une solution à leurs difficultés il vous
faut encore à l'inquiétude des
personnels hospitaliers que l'on se
propose de réorganiser sans ménagement
au transférer leur mission à d'autres
opérations à d'autres opérateurs
il vous faut admettre que les usagers du
système de soins sans que notre système
se délite peu à peu en tendant à
substituer la carte de crédit à la carte
vitale
il faut écouter enfin les attentes des
élus locaux qui n'ont pas envie que se
crée deux mains des déserts sanitaires
abandonné des professions libérales de
santé des pouvoirs publics faute d'avoir
fondé votre approche
sur ces problèmes essentiels nous avait
produit une loi partielle et des tasses
et des enjeux du moment en amont vous
avez renoncé je vous l'avais dit dans
mon intervention lors du texte vous avez
renoncé aux grands textes d'orientation
de financement et d'organisation dont le
système de santé français a tant besoin
pour ne traiter qu'une partie du sujet
le volet administratif de l'organisation
des soins
oui madame la ministre nous attendions
une loi ambitieuse ouvrant la voie du
renforcement et de la pérennité d'un
système de soin et nous obtenons en
retour un texte bancal qui réorganise et
l'administration de la santé et règle
quelques questions subalternes et dans
lequel les vrais problèmes ne sont bien
souvent qu'effleurer est pas réellement
traités et parlementaires des deux
chambres d'ailleurs l'ont bien compris
puisqu'ils ont multiplié par trois le
nombre d'articles que compte la loi
malgré les promesses de futurs textes
relatifs à au financement certes c'est
exact puisque le plfss est obligatoire
mais relatifs à la santé publique et la
santé mentale
quid et quand en effet à quoi servons
parvenu au terme de six mois de travaux
et de controverse en matière de
gouvernement de l'hôpital public
le sénat a su faire preuve d' écoute des
acteurs de la santé et vous avez fait
certain contrecoeur dans un certain
nombre de cas
machine arrière mais je vois que vous y
revenez même au dernier moment à travers
un dernier amendement l'article 6
gouvernement est en effet revenu sur ses
intentions les plus caricaturales qui
qualité le fonctionnement de l'hôpital
sur un modèle militaire
de la même façon le caractère facultatif
de l'adhésion une communauté
hospitalière territoire apparaît comme
une bonne modifications soucieuse de
préserver la liberté de gestion des
établissements italiens
même si nous sommes pas dupes des moyens
de pression à disposition de la future
ars dans ce domaine mais les menus
concessions que l'on recense reste bien
dérisoires face aux grands enjeux que ce
texte a soulevé d'abord concernant la
garantie des moyens et du champ
d'intervention de l'hôpital public
rien n'est venu entraver la
généralisation des missions de service
public au privé luc est très lucratif
qui constitue à nos yeux une régression
discutable il ya plus de domaines il n'y
a plus de domaine réservé des finances
publiques
il y avait des accréditations au privé
des possibilités de financions il y aura
désormais le financement intégral des
services médicaux nous savons ce que
cela cache où vous dotez là d'un outil
juridique qui permettra de perfuser la
partie la moins rentable de l'activité
des établissements privés
cela porte un nom la ministre la
socialisation des pertes des cliniques
françaises perdent rentabilité et
attendent un coup de pouce de la
collectivité par le biais du contrat de
service public
elles l'auront et pendant ce temps là
les profits eux resteront privées le
mélange des genres entre secteur privé
lucratif et âge et argent publics
n'annoncent selon nous rien de bon
concernant l'accès aux soins le tel
c'est une déception en matière de
démographie médicale et mesures sont
renvoyées à plus tard le numerus clausus
régionalisé mettra beaucoup de temps à
produire ses effets la mesure coercitive
du contrat santé solidarité est renvoyé
à l'après 2012 le contrat d'engagement
de service public en contrepartie d'une
bourse universitaire produira ses effets
sous dix ans quant aux autres mesures
incitatives
elle existe déjà sur la question des
discriminations dans l'accès aux soins
votre position frôle d'hypocrisie en
refusant l'usagé encadré du testing ou
continuer de considérer
que ce problème n'en est pas un curieuse
posture la discrimination et réprouvait
dans les mots mais ne peut être testé
dans les faits c'est un peu comme de
définir des limitations de vitesse sans
contrôle des excès potentiel à quoi bon
se draper dans des principes protecteur
si aucun moyen n'est mis en place pour
évaluer leurs applications le testing
est aux yeux de certains une suspicion
nous y voyons plutôt une dissuasion
enfin sur les dépassements d'honoraires
c'est le mutisme le plus complet
envoyez une négociation ultérieure entre
les professionnels de santé l'assurance
maladie la question est pour ainsi dire
balayé d'un revers de main même les
parlementaires de votre majorité ont dû
se rendre à l'évidence une véritable
chape de plomb une véritable chape de
plomb caractérise votre la pole et la
position du gouvernement sur ce point
nous connaissons vos raisons nous savons
qu'ils à votre oreille
je vous pose cependant la question at on
encore le droit en république de
contrarier quelques intérêts privés ou
bien l'argent limite est il devenu la
mesure de toute chose
un mot enfin du titre iv et de
l'avènement de la rs qui s'annonce
difficile
par sagesse il est question de reporter
la mise en oeuvre définitive de cette
gigantesque administration à juillet
2010 quel aveu d'impréparation on
découvre soudainement que la fusion
d'administration différentes les unes
dans les autres
va pas de soi qu'il faudra examiner les
conditions d'évolution des agents bref
on découvre qu'ils existent un statut de
la fonction publique
vous venez de suivre les conclusions de
la commission mixte paritaire sur le
projet de loi hôpital patients santé et
territoires pour voir cette séance notre
site internet publicsenat.fr merci de
votre fidélité et à très bientôt sur
public sénat
non